[Music]
hail and farewell this has been an
incredible journey I would just say that
we have the best fans in the world
getting to share that experience with
the fans and have you guys come on this
journey with us has been beyond a dream
come true
a lot of fans reach out to us and they
say like thank you for the strength
you've given me here and like we didn't
we didn't do that we just created the
opportunity for them to find that
strength or to find that version of
themselves they want to discuss things
and talk about things and they notice
every little detail that every
department takes such care to put into
the show and that has been one of the
biggest gifts out of all of this you
don't frown that it's over you smile
that it happens and I think that's the
best way moving forward is you know we
had something wonderful for a little
while here and the fans were a huge part
of that
hail and farewell and you guys have
honestly been the best fans that anyone
could ever ask for because of you I
think we've gone as long as we have but
thank you for the tremendous support
thank you guys for supporting each other
thanks for watching and thinking about
the episodes and chatting about the
episodes with us thanks for tuning in
when we tweeted and the fact that you've
been open to changes and been willing to
come with us on this journey and trust
us with the story that that you know you
guys care about so much it's been
unbelievable and this fandom truly is
unstoppable so I would just say keep on
keep on keeping because these fans have
had really I've learned a lot from them
and
been really incredible experience
everything you did wasn't in vain all
those fan arts all those all those
messages live tweets everything we
really appreciate it and we truly love
you guys thank you what Shadowhunters
fans have done for us I don't think
they've done for anyone else so I thank
them for the love and you know for the
support they've shown each and every
character
[Music]